gold as an investment sucks I told that
last guy that young man before the break
get rid of his gold don't buy gold
okay the average annual rate of return
on gold is about one percent
over the last 70 80 years
over the last five years it has broke
even
if you go back before that it was the
high when everybody was scared to death
that the economy was going to crash a
bunch of people put gold it was 2200 an
ounce now it's 1400 an ounce you would
have lost 34 since then
so that's what Gold's done for you oh by
the way during the five years that gold
broke even the S P's up 34 33 percent
meaning the stock market
and so had you invested in good mutual
funds instead of in Gold you would have
actually made some money in the last
five years
and and so this is what you need to
check on this is what you need to
understand do not put money in a
commodity
commodity is an item
we don't buy corn Futures we don't buy
gemstones
we don't buy silver
we don't buy gold these are commodities
we don't buy any kind of agricultural
Futures and the reason is is that the
item has a set amount of supply and
demand and the only thing or a set
amount of supply and the only thing that
drives the price on it is one of two
things fear or greed you cannot predict
whether somebody is going to be scared
enough to move all their money over into
gold and drive gold prices up or greedy
enough to move all their money out of
gold and drive gold prices down
you can't predict human nature and what
it's going to do
what you can do is do math on assets
that make money
an asset that makes money is not a
commodity
by making money I mean it literally
produces money a company that is that
you know a share of stock is sold in you
can actually look at the profits of the
company you can actually look at things
the company owns you can look at growth
Trends in the profits and the balance
sheets of the companies
profit to earnings ratios p e ratios you
can look and do a financial analysis on
this stock and thereby place a value
that has a mathematical reason for the
value on that share of stock on a group
of stocks it's called a mutual fund
and though the values are derived as a
mathematical process one plus one equals
two not oh God I'm so scared I'm going
to buy gold that's you know a guy with
bad teeth that was on TV 25 years ago
following the Snuggie commercial and the
walk-in bathtub commercial on cable news
is trying to sell you gold
right beside a reverse mortgage
this is where you buy your Investments
right next to Snuggies and walk-in
bathtubs that's not a clue
that is a clue don't do it
okay so stay away from gold it has a
horrible rate of return stay away from
Commodities of any kind
I buy things that have a mathematical
predictable thereby rate of return I can
actually forecast based on what it's
done in the past
past returns are not guarantees of
future returns well no they're not
guarantees but they are indicative it's
the only forecasting method that there
really is
and if it's zero past returns you don't
know what the flip you're buying into
that's why I knew a company going you
know going on the stock market initial
public offering an IPO for the first
time is so difficult to Value because
you get information from about what the
company used to make when it was private
and it's supposed to be documented but
it's seeing it's all about staging that
stock price and so IPOs are just
dangerous
I like my things that are predictable
when I buy a piece of real estate I
don't buy the real estate based on
anything except the money that it makes
it makes this much rent and that is our
X return on the amount of investment
I've made
and that's what you're looking for is a
return on investment
so this is why you don't do that